على كل مشاهدينا دعونا نتحدث عن ملف اخر
ويتعلق بدعم المتظاهرين الايرانيين سيما
من النواحي التقنيه وايضا الانترنت فقد
تاكد رئيس شركه سبايس اكس طبعا نتحدث هنا
عن ايرون ماسك ان نحو مئه محطه استقبال
ارضيه لخدمات الانترنت المؤمنه عبر شبكه
ستارلينج تعمل حاليا في ايران في اطار
وعوده اي ماسك لاتاحه الانترنت للايرانيين
فما هي سترلينج وكيف تعمل في الداخل
الايراني تحديدا ستارلينج التي يمتلكها
ماسك لديها حاليا اكثر من الفي قمر
اصطناعي صغير طبعا تدور حول الارض في مدار
منخفض ما يعني ان الاشارات ستصل وبقوه
اعلى الى مساحات اكثر مقارنه طبعا بتلك
التي يعطيها قمر الاتصالات التقليديه
ويتعين وجود محطات استقبال ارضيه للاتصال
بهذه الاقمار والحصول على الانترنت
وبالتالي توزيع الخدمه للمستخدمين المحطات
الارض تتمثل في طبق استقبال ذات التوجيه
يتم تثبيته اعلى المنزل ويتصل بسرعه طالما
ان السماء صافيه ثم يتم توصيله بجهاز يوزع
الاشاره لاسلكيا داخل المنزل اي يطلع بدور
الراوتر وفي وقت لم يعرف بعد عدد الاجهزه
الموجوده على الاراضي الايرانيه اكد
انشطاء وصول اولى الاطباق الى داخل ايران
بطبيعه الحال يتم تهريب هذه الاجهزه حيث
يعمل المهربون خاصه في المناطق الحدوديه
الكرديه على اعاده تعبئه الاجهزه في
صناديق مخصصه لافران الميكرويف او طبعا
غيرها من الادوات المنزليه بحسب وول ستريت
جورنال للحصول على مواقع هذه الاجهزه داخل
الاراضي الايرانيه يعتمد النظام الايراني
على اجهزه مراقبه لتحديد مواقع النشاط
الايرانيين يراقبون بشكل دائم اقتراب تلك
الاجهزه ويقومون باطفائها بين الفينه
والاخرى كما يقومون كثير مواقعها وذلك
بشكل دوري
[موسيقى]